if you believe all are created equal
come to self join us join our march
against injustice and in human this
little guy and pretty much everything
else in town has to take four separate
plane rides to arrive up here in Chile
Barrow Alaska
from what do you care where from with
Arkansas yeah I mean worried for a
second this is where you tell me all
about how yep the insects like me
shouldn't be surfing the break and all
that right that would be a waste of time
trying to pick up any bait you shot a
man on the back of not taking you in to
hang for this Thanksgiving no yelling no
hysteria language was developed for one
endeavor and that is to communicate no -
woo
when mr. Cady
[Music]
just drop me off here I'll catch a cab
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my $20 but I don't
[Music]
I managed in a few decades to marry the
two most worthless men in the universe
and then proceeded to have the three
most ungrateful children ever conceived
[Music]
you just got finished reading some axial
historian a garrison probably gonna be
convinced to that till next month when
you get to James lemon and I baked the
court I I baked the court to let me cut
into the Apple
[Music]
I'll never leave Montana brother
[Music]
you sure you're qualified to be taking
care of that baby
are you talking about how the baby
before we found the baby yeah coffee
bean
[Music]
now the first one was completed and
fully operational before Terrell was
destroyed it
incredible credits and the second one
was still being built when they blew it
up
compliments of Lando Calrissian had
breakfast here read your paper thought
you might be interested in my reaction
you bet I am
well sir it made me throw up by shaking
me off huh want to bring the heaters
announcement president Luthor - not sure
what my present for the port
[Music]
Biagio good effort although very poorly
planned out and savagely racist
[Music]
[Music]
having ttan
I guess you're about the best looking
gal we've seen around here in a long
time that's a very nice going and I'm
gonna tell my husband I've met with your
approval
[Music]
you distinguish yourself by not calling
for days you instable that's a very nice
hat you're wearing and I don't mean that
good that you asked March mr. Arnoff
Boone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was wicked man you ain't gonna
drink that in here you guessed it
you
you